[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in this video we'll be discussing
harry potter and his relationship with
the dursleys
now it's no secret that harry and the
dursleys never exactly saw eye to eye
and 99 of the time i think that you
could argue
that this toxic relationship is the
faults of the dursleys
however one consideration that i had was
that perhaps the dursleys were
influenced
by the long exposure to harry torcrux i
don't think that the horcrux
possesses the ability to completely
change them as people
but perhaps it exposes and exaggerates
their inner darker nature
realistically the dursleys were beyond
mean to harry
and were actually quite abusive he was
like their lowly servant
and was punished in unthinkable ways
including locking him in a closet
putting bars on his window and even
preventing him from accessing his own
mail
they were terrible however they seemed
to really love each other
and acted quite civil with other members
of society
this makes me wonder why did harry
incite such rage in them
why did the dursleys hate magical folk
with such a passion
rather than celebrate harry like the
rest of the wizarding world
he was trodden on the truth is that the
dursleys hated
any and everything that wasn't normal
harry's aunt petunia was the sister to
harry's mother
lily and petunia's parents always
preferred lily over her
or at least that's the resentful belief
that she held
this insane jealousy of course stemming
from lily's innate magical ability
something that petunia did not possess
but secretly longed for
this jealousy started off in a harmless
way and eventually led to her despising
anything anyone and everything magical
in fact when she met vernon they bonded
over normalcy
it was the union of two people who
cherished the mundane
consistent and predictable when petunia
eventually confessed to vernon that her
sister was a witch
she was unsure of what vernon would
think but they got past it
and eventually bonded over her very own
sister being a freak
so if she was willing to say such awful
things towards her own sister it's no
surprise that she would have
very little interest in her offspring
petunia is really just a very petty
person driven
by extreme jealousy there are plenty of
lines in the very first chapter of the
philosopher's stone
that would indicate they are just
terrible people mrs potter was mrs
dursley's sister
but they hadn't met for several years in
fact mrs stursley
pretended she didn't have a sister
because her sister and her good for
nothing husband
were as underslee-ish as it was possible
to be
the dursleys knew that the potters had a
small son too but they had never even
seen him
the boy was another good reason for
keeping the potters away and they didn't
want dudley mixing with a child
like that we don't know a lot about
harry's relationship with the dursleys
before the philosopher's stone takes
place
and we don't know how they treated him
as a baby harry was left on their
doorstep
at such a young age and i really can't
see how instead of mistreating him
they wouldn't have just tried to raise
him as their own this was a baby who had
no preconceptions about anything
at all and they would have been able to
meld this baby into someone just like
them
if they gave it a chance they could have
at least tried
fast forward to the philosopher's stone
and the jerseys are up to their usual
antics
locking harry in a cupboard treating him
like a servant and just generally
abusing him
my theory is that harry's relationship
with the dursleys deteriorated
over time and that it was better towards
the beginning the basis of this theory
is that because of their prolonged
exposure to a horcrux it affected their
behavior in the way that they perceived
the world if the dircies were as mean as
we know them to be right from the
beginning
i can't see why they wouldn't have just
put him in an orphanage or something
this was the offspring of the sister
that she hated surely she wouldn't have
raised harry at all
if she actually hated him as much as it
appears she does later in the books
films the only thing that comes to mind
for why petunia may have
begrudgingly accepted harry into her
home is the fact that dumordal left her
a letter
explaining the unique circumstances for
his adoption
in fact dumbledore knew that they would
need some convincing which is why he
left a letter rationalizing the
situation
in the first place dumbledore's letter
to the dersis was not particularly
extensive
or descriptive but it did highlight a
couple of the very important events that
had transpired
as well as explain what kind of action
he would need from them moving forward
the first thing that dumbledore
explained was that james and petunia's
sister lily had been tragically murdered
despite the fact that petunia had
written off lily from her life this must
have been hard news to swallow
and truly eye-opening with regards to
the danger of the wizarding world
next damodal explained lily's loving
sacrifice and the magical protection
that would befall a number four privet
drive
after harry was adopted this is probably
the most important aspect of them taking
harry in
as if they didn't it could cost him his
life and lastly
dumbledore explained the dangers of what
could potentially happen to both harry
and the dursley family if harry were to
leave the house before his 17th birthday
when the protection from the loving
sacrifice would finally end
it's untelling which part of this letter
actually convinced the dursleys to take
harry in
whether it was the concern for his life
or whether it was just them looking out
for themselves
either way they did end up taking him in
but they didn't exactly do it
gracefully as we know horcruxes can
seriously affect people's behavior
and makes them behave in a much more
negative manner this manner gets
progressively worse the more that you
are exposed to the horcrux
we see this same sort of behavior in ron
when he wears slytherin's
rockets around his neck and deathly
hallows over
time he becomes moodier and moodier with
each passing minute becoming less and
less
like himself so perhaps the jerseys were
affected
to a lesser extent the same way that ron
was affected
however if harry's horcrux makes people
angrier you might argue that it would
have had more of an effect on his close
friends in the series
my argument for this is that in the
dursley household harry would have had
the closest
proximity to other people for longer
periods of time at hogwarts harry would
run around
all over the place and had plenty of
distance between him and others
in his sleeping quarters additionally
perhaps the severity of the negative
effect that horcruxes give off
is totally dependent on the person
that's exposed to it
maybe some aren't affected at all while
others are crippled by it
the dursleys are just muggles so maybe
it was just too much for them
maybe the horcrux in harry wasn't enough
to affect magical folk
one other thing worth mentioning is that
harry isn't a full-blown horcrux
when voldemort tried to kill harry the
curse rebounded which split voldemort's
soul
but because voldemort's body was gone
the victim of his own curse
he could no longer encase the soul
fragment to complete the horcrux
formation
part of horcrux creation involves an
encasing spell which actually puts the
soul
outside of the body into a physical
object because voldemort's soul was left
without any attachment
it latched itself to harry for this
reason harry contained voldemort's soul
fragment
but was never possessed by it therefore
he did not possess a lot of the main
characteristics of a horcrux
perhaps the fact that harry was not a
proper horcrux
meant that those around him were
affected to a lesser extent than
exposure to
other horcruxes maybe magical folk were
completely fine around him
but it was just too much for muggles to
handle while the jerseys are just
terrible people in general i like to
think that they weren't always
quite so bad maybe at one point in time
they really did care about harry
even if only a little bit and it was
just that the horcrux was too much
what do you guys think did harry make
the dursleys that much meaner
or were they awful to begin with let me
know in the comment section
below until next time it does not do to
dwell on dreams
and forget to live
[Music]
you